Jhin perhaps the panelists have thoughts
about but also just for the room one of
the things that strikes me about our our
conversations is how qualified and
tempered and humble much of the computer
science presentations the framing is we
don't know things we are still working
on things that's very tempered and
thinking about the kind of private face
of computer science versus the public
claims whether the computer scientists
make but also others make on your behalf
about what the power of this field can
do and so in sociology we have a long
history of studying what we call the
Janus face of science that is lower case
science and all of the ways in which
it's social and it's and its political
and it's you know the the it's a human
endeavor versus capital S science in
which to get the grants or to get the
attention you make it overly overly
powerful in its predictions or its path
and so thinking about that what
responsibilities do you have as members
of the field to either let that play out
get the get the that get the benefits of
the public face while being humble and
qualified in private or do you have a
responsibility to address that gap and
one of the very specific specific quotes
I'm thinking about is this New York
Times article that came out profiling
Donald Knuth one of the I'm not saying
it's last name but one of the founders
of computer science the article you
should read is called like the Yoda of
Silicon Valley it's a great article and
in there too we're at the very end the
last paragraph he says in the beginning
we were so worried no one was paying
attention to us now I'm worried too many
people are paying attention to us and so
what responsibilities do you have and
how can we support you in your endeavors
to own up to the fact that these
predictions and this the claims made on
behalf of the field are not
they are made out to be give grants to
people with with specific words as
opposed to averaging grandma use plan
claim get some money yeah and I mean I
mean it both in an academic and
non-academic sense right everyone wants
to give money to Elon Musk
singing money tank Elon Musk and no one
wants to give money to as many people in
this room I think knowing when you hear
snake oil right if you hear in general a
piece of technology is going to solve
some grand task you should know it's
both/and and don't give it your time
attention money
I think that's a good start I think
another is - one thing that I would like
to come out of this workshop is a set of
shared resources information resources
and with you calling out this particular
issue I realized that we should we
should make clear here are some here are
some reasons for skepticism and here are
good papers that that Express the
skepticism and the limits and this is
where we think you know the real
theoretical work sorry the real science
whether it's computer science or
theoretical computer science or
something else in CS this is where we
think it is I assume that in other
fields that are represented here you
have the same issues and it might be
good to to collect high-quality starting
points or reading points from from the
different fields yeah I think are we
being too timid in our suggestions what
else do you want to hear writing down
things I think it's a great set of
interventions thank you so much for all
you know we tried to do this there was a
series of working groups put on it Duke
University Charmaine Royale and Mike
Baum Schad were really I think the main
organizers around trying to figure out
some way that genetic testing and
ancestry and all of these different
technologies could find a gold standard
or just some consensus statements and
there were these really just you know
detailed minority reports so we had
these clickers and we'd all vote on we
do workshops and breakout into small
groups it was a lot of work and there
was a sense that these would be
published somewhere they never were and
I think it goes back to some of what has
been alluded to
in terms some of the genetic stocks is
that there is quite a bit of work being
done in in academia which is more open
and grant funded etc but there's quite a
bit that's done in the private sphere
and living in Silicon Valley it's pretty
clear that it's even worse in this case
right in terms of the the way people are
validated right the kind of Facebook
move fast and break things there is a
sense of we don't really have to play by
the rules and so I think it would be
great you know to follow on Cynthia's
point if people in you know some circles
of computing and computer science did
come up with us you know a really
important set of papers like paper one
paper to paper three the kinds of things
that you know show the architecture show
the problems show the limitations and
really create a conversation around kind
of from computing science ethics if you
will and try to come to some consensus I
think that the the issue with the with
the parallel that I'm bringing up with
the genetic testing industry is that
people already had companies they were
already invested in certain certain
directions in certain domains it's very
hard to get those people to agree on on
something and a lot of it was
proprietary they didn't want to talk
about what they could share and so I do
think it would be important to have a
set of papers from within the field
write a very thoughtful people like
yourselves I think something else that
would be really good that just occurs to
me now is to have an informed critique
of papers that make certain kinds of
claims but by informed I actually mean
by informed with the expertise of the
other people in this room so to match up
with a computer scientist and go through
what the claims are and then give the
bigger context the kinds of things that
we've been talking about
I think that would be incredibly
powerful Helen wants to talk
I am going a little back in the weeds
versus this great question that we
started discussing and it has to do with
this discussion of features so it has a
little maybe it's of cynthia's and
Jaime's anyone can answer he can and it
started off with Maritza's talk this
morning in that you know in in this in
in the in the function which way it goes
race and then you have these exogenous
factors so the question first of all
Cynthia are we in your discussion
are we talking always supervised
learning and in that sense are we always
relying on the analyst to make a
decision about what features and you
know in in your reduction of
dimensionality I know there's a
mathematical part of it that I didn't
follow but but it's sort of as if
there's a preconception about which
features are salient that must come from
what you want out on the on the other
end like what the scientist does is say
well you know I think these on these
features are systematically related to
the output that I mean interested in so
you kind of look at a particular you
focus or you gather your data on a
particular set of features and so when
we the public are hearing all of these
fantastical claims about machine
learning we're given to believe that you
know they're these smart machines and
you just like put them out into the
world and they learn stuff you know this
there's hardly anything that that the
human has to go in and do but what I'm
hearing from some of the talks and even
the you know the remember the one about
language King King and doctor nurse or
doctor doctor like it's very driven
by the output that is of interest so it
is not surprising to me that bias and
discrimination or unfair discrimination
would be the upshot if the computer
scientist or any scientist is sort of
playing the social scientist as they
gather the data together uh there's some
coherence in what I'm trying to yeah I I
do think one of them so I like your
question sort of saying like we should
be thinking about the features we
collect as salient for the task we're
ultimately performing best case scenario
totally agree with you practical
application of how most people talk
about and use machine learning i won't i
won't critique that here but i I think
in general like computer scientists like
to abstract and like to be
general-purpose
that is like general purpose as general
as humanly possible is like a
fundamental tenet of computing great
like ignore as much detail as possible
about the problem and like abstract that
all away and like come up with the most
general purpose solution
I mean maybe being unkind to computer
science but like I think in general the
like break these into little pieces that
you can reuse in as many other places as
possible is fundamental to the way
computer scientists think about solving
problems and so I think an example is
sort of all this stuff we can do for
machine learning without thinking about
what we're altima trying to use the
system for but let me add I mentioned
some work in progress toward the end of
the talk and I talked about explicitly
you know having a test for saying that
the features in the data are are not
sufficient for the task and so I want to
explicitly call out the option
of a learning algorithm and I was
thinking in terms of supervised learning
and I'll tell you why in a second but
while learning and learning algorithm
I'm saying these data of craps you know
we can't do what you want us to do with
them and the attitude in general as
always will we do the best we can given
the data and under certain circumstances
that may make perfect sense you've got
some horrible new plague and you're just
doing everything you can to try but but
a lot of times you can just say no you
can reject the premise and I think that
we need to have this explicitly called
out in the algorithms and one of the
reasons by the way for not using I mean
for thinking that I like to think more
about the supervised case rather than
the unsupervised case is that if you
haven't I mean I'm not an expert but
what little let me know about
unsupervised learning there is some sort
of implicit distance involved it's like
when you talk about clustering you're
sort of saying well these guys are close
to each other compared to these others
well close to means you need a metric
for determining closeness so if you're
going to do that you need a metric and
then I don't know that's a hard problem
hey so um based okay kind of based on
what Ruhollah was asking I was in the
manifesto movement group yesterday and
kind of one of the points I that came up
I wrote a few bullet points the the main
two though the first two that I really
think are something we really need to
ask ourselves are should we have a
political ideology as a group
algorithmic fairness I think typically
the theoretical computer science because
it can with complexity theory in the
sort can take in a political stance on
things but in a political stance is a
political stance and in this case when
we when there are big claims in the
media or the sort
there are riff mutations sometimes
scientist speak out but the refutations
are like well you know technically in
this scenario won't work this way in
that way and it gets really technical
real quick and that itself can be timid
in kind of the way Ruhal was talking so
why should we have a political stance as
a field of algorithmic fairness and I
guess as far as movement goes it feels
like there's a big cultural component to
this the way we write our papers and
abstracts are we going to have an
apolitical nature or are we going to
from the get-go have a
cohesive political ideology that we
decide upon as a field in defining a
movement or a manifesto
I'm wondering if your column announcer
so my guess is that the its Dierdre and
you're gonna have a mic please
every decision is political we started
off the workshop saying fairness is
political I wanted to pick out like the
norm shaping and and how do you get it
out there and here we have this
algorithmic fairness and opacity working
group you have people who are doing work
from a range of different fields coming
in good a scholar Hoyt long who's been
using machine learning techniques but to
to understand literary text and the
thing and Andy smart could actually talk
to us probably too but one of the things
that was most interesting to me in
reading his article in contrast to some
of the other articles was how specific
in detailed he was about the subjective
choices of his algorithms the data that
like and it was so beautiful and it
would be really interesting I think to
actually have some computer scientists
in in Theory read that paper and to
think about the ways in which you might
use the approaches to being specific and
I think it goes to the single purpose
what was the rest of that yeah a single
case purpose-built like actually
treating everything as it was this very
bespoke thing and you know it's it's
like the methodology is so explicit and
you don't ever see that as I think you
were saying or it's not for grounded and
it might be interesting to just look at
different ways in which you might talk
about the choices and so that might be
something that would be really
productive is to look at some of these
other disciplines that are using machine
learning tools and how they talk about
their choices because I think you can do
it in a more kind of bottom-up way to
which informs the way everybody starts
to talk about their work rather than
just having it be in the media because
that you know culture change don't often
has to come up from the bottom but let
me not duck the thing too much long
so in order not to duck completely I
think the answer is yes that I don't
know whether I would use the word
political but having really
well-informed principles and guidelines
and calling for adherence to those I
think is the right thing to do I don't
necessarily know how to write them and
what should be included but that again
should be one of the you know that would
be a major accomplishment so the
workshop would be to start something
like that
I actually think those two are very
related you know people are I think
especially within science there are so
many ways of the science March as such
kind of devolved and not devolved but
you know in an interesting way
bifurcated splintered into these
different conversations about how
science is over he's already political
because some people were wondering
should they even be out there and other
people were saying oh it's always been
political and by the way we've been left
out marginalized and you've been
experimenting on us etc so science is
always political like most things in
culture but I think calling it
explicitly political or having a
manifesto
you know raises the hackles and some in
some domains and I think that that might
be fine if that's what you want to do it
but there's an acknowledgement that it
needs to happen right but it's always
already in a social context that is
highly politicized and we take certain
things for granted in ways that are
legacy effects of imperialism
colonialism capitalism all these things
but what she just pointed to Deidre in
terms of that paper and really having
authors be conscious and explicitly
state where they're coming from it's
called a sort of like Donna Haraway
situated knowledge is a very old essay
sort of this feminist you know science
studies approach to all knowledge has a
home and has a kind of a place of mind
from which it stems etc and so I think
bridging those two approaches I don't
know if manifesto is the right word
after the you know
but you need two uniforms I'm not sure
but there is a there is a way to
explicitly acknowledge that science is
not neutral or objective and we can do
all kinds of things to try and get
better outcomes but I sometimes think
acknowledging the politics and including
them might actually lead to some better
outcomes sort of like your was the term
pseudo randomness stuff just
incorporating that into the algorithm
the algorithm is if that's possible
right then what we don't know and so I
will want to thank all the presenters
over here thank all the presenters for
their appropriate modesty but I have
been studying a lot the collapse of
civilizations and we seem to be on the
edge of collapse with climate change and
other very complicated problems and a
lot of it's non scientists look to
science to sort of oh you guys will come
up with the answer or even other
scientists do and could you just talk a
little more about that in the context of
what I see is a collapsing civilization
I I do think if we're talking about the
context of climate change science does
have some solutions people don't want to
hear them and people don't want to
implement them and don't want to take
responsibility I'm in no way an expert
and political things aside I think in
general it's interesting to think about
whether science is in the business of
persuading because I think in general we
don't think of what we're doing as like
trying to convince anyone of anything we
say here's the evidence we have and I
think that maybe we should talk about
whether or not we're in the business of
persuasion outside of outside of science
but maybe inside as well I guess we do
it inside
[Music]
so perhaps to follow up on a couple of
the earlier comments about sort of the
political issues here and this is again
sort of an overarching comment about the
the conferences I've been a little
uncomfortable with even the sort of
terminology and algorithmic fairness and
to think about this or relationships
between are we talking about fairness
are we talking about neutrality are we
talking about justice because
algorithmic fairness you know tends to
leave exists that the concept to my mind
can't sleep pre-existing distributions
of power sort of in place and then we're
sort of like how do we get the fairness
and then as I was thinking through this
I was thinking well okay so there you
know there's this y-you know very widely
regular book out their algorithms of
oppression which has been getting a lot
of attention and just occurred to me
well algorithms of oppression rights or
presupposes the idea of algorithms of
liberation right and so should we be
talking about right is it possible to
talk about algorithms of liberation
algorithms of reparation algorithms of
abolition I have no idea because I
wouldn't know an algorithm at that bit
me in the butt but I am curious right to
think about the algorithms in those
terms so moving away from fairness to
justice
[Music]
you know where my they manifest what my
day look like so I think
one thing that they might do is uncover
or discover sorry I'm losing my language
uncover or discover pernicious
interactions and behaviors and effects
and comb through lots and lots of
history and data and pull things out and
then exhibit it for well the evidence
and now what do we do next but so a lot
of sort of useful monitoring and testing
if I can understand how to do these
these tests yeah well I think we need to
listen to the people who are talking
about abolition and help them I'm not
abolition like if you're talking about
algorithms of abolition we need to talk
to the people who have been thinking
about abolition for a long time and help
them like I don't think we have like we
may have tools that can help but I think
we're not going to discover something
new or better than they've already
thought about and we can think about how
the tools we have can help
there are many realms in which
algorithms are objectively helpful and
useful and algorithms for medicine that
you know control your your your
pacemakers and I mean they're just tons
and tons of beneficial uses if you if
your brain were like wildly
computationally effective
how would you deploy it to a mask
what would you do if you had all of the
thinking power and speaking power that
you needed what would you do to
affect the balance of power Nancy can
answer right or it looks like actually
it looks like that has a comment
prepared so that aside the only I I
thought of this I you all probably were
aware of the fact that like right around
when the ACA was like it was looking as
though the ACA might be repealed there
was a very simple piece of software that
someone wrote which allowed you to text
to a fax machine we talked about faxes
earlier today and we flooded the input
to all of the fax machines on Capitol
Hill and I do think like you know I know
that's not like technologically like
fascinating from the computing
perspective but like like simple ideas
like that can be pretty effective as
agents of you know change I just wanted
to say that we have about five people in
line we can yet we can we can do this we
could take all the questions at one time
I know that we're sort of at the end of
our time but we're also at the end of
the day so we can I don't know what your
preferences Cynthia you decide okay is
it okay I'm asking if we I think I think
which we take these questions can extend
that time so I wanted to go back to the
first few questions
we're Deirdre mentioned the norms in the
field and I think Helen was amazing
sorry but effectively it's like
perspectives in sorry yes um and I want
to push back on Jamie and Cynthia a
little bit because as I'm a computer
science PhD in my trajectory with other
interdisciplinary your science PhDs ends
up being that this type of work tends
not to be rewarded if you go to specific
if you talk about context that's for
that's a specialized field and so I
don't think it's quite fair to say like
oh well we're just computer scientists
everything has to be general that's for
the specialists to do and I think that
actually hinders us and sort of
rewarding the type of work that
considers the social and political
contexts of the work that we're doing so
could you I mean
revisit that a little bit in terms of
what we can do for valuing this kind of
work inside of our field because
otherwise I think it self included we
just leave the field so
[Laughter]
I think that if you have a very
domain-specific are you talking about
having some kind of very domain specific
application or I mean talking about
little context of an algorithm is you're
you're asking me about what to do about
certain kinds making sure that certain
kinds of computer science work is
rewarded can you elaborate on what kinds
of computer science work you mean can
you rewards it crimes of work give me an
example well so ACM making past our Navy
on Congress is a great step but that was
that's one of our only examples of
rewarding of kind of political simple
context within you know otherwise these
subfields get hard
what kind of work give me an example of
the kind of work that just like a
particular sort of thing much of what
we've heard here
I think since I can't get an answer out
of you let me make up what you might
have in mind and we'll go with that for
night if so so let's suppose that you
found you so you did a very in-depth and
now you did something that has to do
with loans you did some kind of work
that has to do with loans and you had
managed to find a way of doing a better
prediction that was less objectionable
and also accurate and so on I think that
there are a lot of ways of getting that
really recognized in fact there's a lot
of pressure in the other direction
it's like what are you doing writing
about this general stuff we want to see
you work with real data sets and have an
impact on real people too
so I'm saying there there I think that
you can get a lot of recognition for
that sort of work are you saying from an
academic perspective specifically social
context of our algorithms what the right
norms within computer science as a field
as we teach students and as we have even
just learned the number of venues we
have that kind of supports to allow this
so I think that so in fact let me
Rheingold and I are actually trying
we're working to start a new conference
for mathematically strong research in
exactly this field
I mean well in general it doesn't have a
name yet
I don't think but it will be four four
four computer science that has an impact
on social issues and fairness would be
forgiven use of the term fairness would
be an example privacy would be an
example as well so we agreed that we
need venues more venues that recognize
exactly this kind of work and so and
also the Journal of privacy and
confidentiality will periodically have
special issues that go beyond privacy
and confidentiality to other issues of
social questions I yeah just kind of I
guess piggybacking off of a lot of the
points that we're just drunk together
and coming directly from an
undergraduate institution and a liberal
arts one that that which you might
expect to have more interdisciplinary
talk in a computer science education I
think it shouldn't be like it's
important to talk about academic expert
or like expert academia but then I think
it's really like has somebody whose most
of my cohort from that undergraduate
institution went into industry and like
will be ml practitioners but who don't
hold a vocabulary to interrogate the
social context behind the practicing
that they do and this is I guess less of
a question more like Oh what do you
think of this I I think like it
shouldn't be underestimated how early
that education of vocabulary should
start like this should be and directly
off of the last point actually like the
norm should be present from the start of
learning algorithms like we can't
divorce the context clearly and like I
feel like also what I've heard for most
people computer scientists specifically
at this conference has been like how
interesting it is to finally have an
interdisciplinary talk that's so
interdisciplinary like massively
interdisciplinary and to have that
really from the get-go because I have no
idea what it's even like in an
engineering department like again have a
couple of comments first of all I don't
want the pendulum to swing too far you
know you really do have to understand
depth-first search you thought that it
didn't get all of the mechanics of
algorithms and other parts of computer
science Harvard is working has a program
where with with embedded ethics modules
so more and more computer science
courses will have an emphasis coming in
and doing it doing some education and we
want to push that I think earlier and
earlier there are other pedagogical
innovations Martha Minow and I are
teaching two courses that are
intertwined one is a straight computer
science course on this topic and some
other topics and the other is a course
in the law school and the courses will
meet together once a week and separately
each once a week
- and part of the 1:1 aspect will be
cross-cultural dialogue it's going to be
a requirement is presenting things that
people with a different education
intellectual tradition can understand
did the pedagogy group were you in the
pedagogy yeah the small but very
passionate pedagogy here I just I do
want to observe that it seems like some
of the questions are overlapping with
the next section which we can blend in
to but if if there are those in the line
who would prefer to take their questions
for the next section which is general
feedback and ethics and norms yes yeah
we can say that or we can just let this
blend in to the next one but I think
Nancy was next language three quick
comments that relate to these different
themes one is that these kinds of
questions have come up repeatedly in
every single scientific discipline in
very clear form since at least the early
1900's there earlier debates that can be
traced but there is a particular
conference in 1930 that really put this
all on the map in terms of the tensions
within science so it's to be expected
that the social conflicts that are in
the world that we live in manifested in
the science that we do because we live
in this world it's very helpful to get a
historical perspective to understand
also other disciplines scientific
disciplines have engaged with these
issues of where a political is confused
with not being clear on what your values
are or confusing objectivity with being
a political because those are not the
same things whatsoever you do want to do
rigorous science that others can
replicate assuming that you had the same
worldview and starting questions but
that's the big assumption in terms of
who's asking which questions and coming
with what sets of assumptions of what is
relevant or not needed to actually test
your questions this gets debated and
field after field dueña can speak you
know just about anthropology and the
extraordinary splits between the
physical anthropologists and the
cultural anthropologists and the the
fights that have been written I can
speak about it in epidemiology
I'm sure others that are here from other
disciplines in sociology can speak about
the fights between the people that take
a fundamental method or logic
individualist approach versus a approach
that deals with populations is not as
more than just simply sums of
individuals so this is normal and it's
good to have a frame where you can
situate your own science in the context
of money other debates that have
happened in science and I think with
regard to what that means also for the
pedagogy is actually making sure there's
an introductory course I teach an
introductory course that's for all
population health science PhD students
which is about history politics and
public health theories of disease
distribution across time and culture
saying that look you want to understand
a you have to understand a distribution
be a population see how different groups
have thought about this and fought in
every single generation over time about
what the issues are as also the
phenomena itself is changing the
societies change the disease's patterns
change so how do you think about that
and give that and that's for people that
have been like in not just in
epidemiology but it's a lot of the
different fields that's really really
critical and I developed that course
having studied here and gotten my PhD
here at Berkeley and been really
frustrated that nobody taught me what I
wanted to know I had to go do all this
other reading and then I developed a
course on the side out of my first job
when I was working at Kaiser and I like
negotiated a different working for long
days of weeks like I spend the fifth day
as it were in the library and taught
that course on training wheels here and
then took it to where I next one and
it's also saying you're recognizing that
there's a gap go fill it and draw on
people to do that and I think that
there's there and I think it's again not
also conflating science equals a
objectivity or B truth but understanding
that's what is so wonderfully human
about science is people coming together
and also acting independently to try to
test the ideas to get a deep
understanding of causal processes
whatever those things are to turn it
into knowledge that could potentially be
just beautiful or useful but the moment
you start dealing with how humans are
living and dying it damn well better be
more than just useful
hi I wanted to ask a completely
different question which is so we were
talking a little bit about into the the
overwhelming need to opt people in now
right so people will say oh well we need
more black faces we need more examples
one of the the things that's disturbed
me about a lot of the current literature
around facial recognition is there's a
whole other literature on how bad we are
at matching faces to pictures right so I
think they tested like passport check
officers and some of them are wrong
like an abnormally large percentage of
the time like they're no better than
random and so I'm wondering is there any
recognition in you know sort of the like
DNA to face sort of community the
communities that are like looking at
these kinds of these translations is
there a recognition that when you get to
that end product it's not going to help
you because we're just really bad at
using that end product
unfortunately no not in the account in
the actual community that's developing
these products there is a lot of hype
that in fact they will produce very
precise faces now when that happens if
it happens we'll all hear about it right
because it will be this sort of slam
dunk but so far there have been almost a
dozen cases now where those faces have
been made since 2015 and there hasn't
been an exact match to the DNA at the
crime scene now when Andrew Pollock
wrote that article the scientists
actually generated faces for the science
editorial team at the New York Times and
the science desk has about 50 or so
people working at the science desk and
so imagine you're in your department and
someone generates the DNA face for all
your colleagues so you see every day now
people could not recognize
a major guy at the New York Times from
the face that was generated they could
recognize a woman she was the only
minority and though okay and she was
female so that was sort of easier but in
terms of no better than random you know
it's on that level and so there is not a
lot of humility or you know just a
spaciousness around this problem that Oh
perhaps we could be doing this
differently or this is not going to be
exact I guess it's the like I believe
that maybe it's possible that someday
you could do even a semi-perfect mapping
but there is research that suggests that
when you have the perfect mapping the
actual photograph of the person yeah we
can't use it which is fascinating even
if you have the perfect mapping in terms
of the photograph it's not precise
and we should probably take a break now
[Music]
[Applause]